你如果是相對久遠的未來,
那基本上你可以承擔風險的能力就很高。
所以真正的重點應該就是在建立紀律。
對於年輕人來說,
固定投資的紀律性是再重要也不過的。
很多人一出社會談理財
就會急著問投資標的跟比例
不過呢25到35歲
真正重要的並不是報酬率
而是你是否已經開始累積
屬於自己的無形資產
今天我們邀請到陳彥璐教授
和我們一起從人生階段的角度
來談談年輕人該如何找到
屬於自己的人生方向與定位
那在節目開始之前也不要忘記
訂閱按贊開啟小鈴鐺
以免錯過最新的節目喔
讓我們歡迎今天的來賓陳彥璐教授
教授您好
你好 很高興今天又再次來到這個地方
老師您曾經提到說
25歲剛畢業其實是職場上被看見
也同時是累積無形資產的一個階段
那您會認為這個階段
人生定位比投資報酬率更重要嗎
那為什麼呢
是的 沒錯
因為這個階段在看到的投資報酬率
可能不是隻有金錢上的投資報酬率
而是你自己對你自我的未來
人生期望的報酬率更多一點
年輕人剛畢業的時候其實心中可能都懷有一些些的夢想
對於財務的期望可能也都是會說
希望會賺越多錢越好
但是大家對於越多錢越好這件事情
其實並沒有一個落地的想法
你一開始畢業的時候也是有類似的想法嗎
會啊就是會不知道說現在定義第一桶金到底是幾百萬還是一千萬
對其實你講到很棒的一件事
就是我們要第一桶金做什麼
所以如果我的第一桶金的目標
是我要出國唸書
那這樣子是不是就會比較明確
因為你大概說
我要去唸什麼學校
所以呢我要準備多少錢
這個時候你第一桶金就比較清楚
那另外呢你的第一桶金
如果是想要買房產
譬如說我希望可以在30歲以前
買一個小的房子
那你就要準備一個頭期款
對不對
所以呢你的第一桶金
可能是你想要自產的一個
投期款的目標
可能是300萬到500萬不等
那當然這跟你選擇
什麼樣的房子有關係
那有些年輕人
可能他有一些
自己想要創業的想法
那他的第一桶金
那就是可能跟創業有關係
所以換個角度來說
一個蠻重要的點是
你要先找到你自己真正想做
想發展的方向是什麼
因為沒有一個目標在的時候
你很難去定義你要投資
要這個財務規劃的目標
所以很多時候我們都是要先設定目標
再來思考我們要怎麼做到這件事情
那請問教授
如果年輕人目前對未來的方向
其實還不太確定
那這樣的狀態到底適不適合投資
那應該要先做什麼比較好呢
就是因為你還不是很確定
你未來的方向
所以我想他就反而更需要投資
因為免得等到你找到方向的時候
結果你都一切會來不及
所以事實上我想最應該先做的
就是在你還不瞭解方向的前提之下
你的收入除了應付你平常的生活所需之外
maybe你應該要有一部分的資金
是用在投資你身上
然後去找出你未來的發展方向
那但是呢還是應該維持一個基礎的部位來進行投資
那這個時候的重點是在找尋你個人的未來方向
所以投資的選擇當然就用被動式的投資會對你比較安全
那最重要的目標是要養成一個長期財富累積的一個習慣
因為這個習慣的建構是很難的
等到你想到了等到你方向確定了
等到你對於你自己未來有安心感了才來做投資
反而都有點太晚了
那很多年輕人會說自己存不到錢
您覺得這通常是真的收入不夠
還是其實是跟生活方式
還有花錢的習慣是比較有關係的呢
其實這是一個很好問題
你讓我回想到我自己年輕的時候
我記得我剛畢業的時候
其實薪水也很少
先不談試用期
就是試用期過了之後的薪水
好像也才兩萬四千塊
那當然是三十幾年前的事情
然後所以錢這麼少
我還要租房子
因為我住在外面
所以我就不可能去租一個很貴的房子
對不對
所以我一定要去平衡
衡量就是交通的需要
然後跟我這個房子的需求
所以我們就還要租房子
然後呢就會還要想說
有多少的基本生活花費
那最重要的是
因為我有一個目標
就是我想要出國唸書
所以我一定要養成存錢的習慣
所以呢我當時就是要求自己每個月最少都要存八千
甚至一萬去做投資
那當然當年的投資的選擇沒有現在這麼多
但是存不到錢這件事情事實上
你說是不是跟收入不夠有關係
我想每一個都有關係
但是其實跟你的目標有沒有更大的關係
因為當你有一個目標
你有一個很強的動力要做這件事情
你就會好好的去規劃
你應該用什麼樣的生活方式
那應該要怎麼樣子的花錢習慣
那但是不影響你自我無形自在累積喔
譬如說我當年還是要補英文啊
對不對我還是要補習考
考英文托福考GMAIL啊
這些錢我都還是要花的
所以就是要好好的平衡自己的收入
跟消費的這個關聯性
這件事情很重要
回到投資這件事情
請問燕如教授
25到35歲在投資上
最重要的是承受風險的能力
還是建立一個投資的紀律呢
這個是一個很棒的問題
事實上我們常講一件事就是
你如果沒有承擔風險
你很難在投資上有一個好的報酬
但是承擔風險這件事情跟什麼有關
因為我們是為了未來的需求嘛
那所以它會跟你的未來有多遠有關
因為你的未來如果很遠
你現在是在準備一個比較久遠的未來
那你就有很長的時間
可以去接受這個上下的震盪
那另外一件事情就是
這個金錢的需要必要性
所以如果你是很短的時間之內
譬如說三年後一定要用
然後而且這一筆錢是非用不可
譬如說你幫你小孩存這個教育經費
那小孩教育是絕對不能沒有
對不對
然後而且你可能是小學畢業
然後六年後要念大學
那這個時候六年期間是一箇中期
所以你可以承擔一點風險
可是你是如果是國中畢業
只剩下三年了
那你這三年期間
一下子又到
尤其是如果你是要出國唸書的話
那這錢很多
那你可能就要風險的控管就會下降一點
那你想想看
今天在講25到35
你如果是相對久遠的未來
那基本上你可以承擔風險的能力就很高
所以呢真正的重點應該就是在建立紀律
對於年輕人來說
固定投資的紀律性是再重要也不過的
當市場波動很大的時候
您觀察到年輕投資人最容易犯錯
也最需要小心的錯誤心理通常是什麼呢
波動很大這件事情啊
是很多投資人都很擔心的
那這些很勇敢承擔波動的投資人
其實我看到蠻多很積極的
會去投資在一些衍生性的商品
應該這樣講
期貨選擇權
因為他們在波動很大的時候
其實都有很多這個獲利的機會
那事實上能夠獲利的人
都還是蠻少數的就是了
在這個地方就是因為
大家覺得波動很大
一小群人想要追求波動產生的價值
然後會有很多更多的人
事實上會害怕波動
最近的股票漲到4萬點了
所以很多人很擔心
然後都會想說
老師老師我要不要趕快出場
我們就說其實這個同樣的問題
在去年達到2萬5的時候
或者是今年稍早達到3萬3萬5的時候
都不斷的有人提過
那我們都常講一件事
就是我沒辦法告訴你
你明天會是多少點
搞不好他有可能上去有可能下來
所以呢
在這個時候
你要再回到最原始的
就是你投資的目標是什麼
就是你投資的目標
應該不是這種短期的上下震盪的這個獲利
而是你的投資目標
可能是一箇中期的目標
可能是一個長期的目標
而這些中期的目標
長期目標
他都是需要時間累積的
那如果你是一個固定投資
不管高或低
事實上你就是固定的往你的目標邁進
所以對你來說
這個高和低事實上並沒有太大的影響
所以最大的錯誤心理
就是大家很容易受到這些市場震盪的影響
那如果高你不敢買
低你也不想買
那到底你什麼時候要買呢
那你的長期財富累積的目標
又什麼時候才能達到呢
謝謝彥茹教授今天的分享
那今天這一集我們談的不是該買什麼
投入多少
而是先回到一個最根本的問題
到底是在為了什麼而準備
那下一集呢
我們要來談談36到50歲的沖刺期
在人生責任最重的時期
該如何做好人生與財務規劃的取捨
那最後喜歡我們的影片
也不要忘記訂閱按讚開啟小鈴鐺
那我們下集再見
掰掰